je voudrais tout d'abord mesdames et
messieurs vous remercier toutes et tous
de d'avoir répondu présent à
l'invitation que nous avons lancé
françois dominique et votre serviteur
parce que mesdames et messieurs ce que
nous faisons ce soir est extrêmement
important il s'agit en réalité d'un
geste politique et il faut le prendre
ainsi car comme l'expliqué françois
c'est la première fois que les trois
grandes associations de collectivités
sont ensemble on a tout fait pour nous
diviser depuis des mois on a souvent été
mis en concurrence souvent en
compétition dans le cadre des
différentes constructions législatives
on a essayé de marchander le soutien des
11 des uns contre les autres et au bout
du compte ce soir nous sommes tous
réunis pour défendre une certaine idée
des libertés
[Applaudissements]